par le laxisme de votre politique
d'immigration
cet enfant a été martyrisé violet tué
par une clandestine qui faisait pourtant
l'objet d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire français lola a perdu la vie
parce que vous n'avez pas procédé à
l'expulsion de cette ressortissante qui
n'avait plus rien à faire ici je vais
vous dire les choses comme je les
ressens faire de la petite politique de
la petite peloche
se servir du cercueil d'une gamine de 12
ans comme on se sert d'un marche-pied
c'est une honte monsieur le député
[Applaudissements]
un échange tendu et c'est vrai que je me
dis c'est vrai qu'est-ce que les la
famille de Lola ont envie de voir ça
quelques jours après c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué après il y a d'autres
gens qui disent aussi il faut faire
quelque chose parce que on n'a pas envie
que ça
ça serait utile alors la suspecte
n'aurait pas dû se trouver sur le
territoire français c'est ça
moi je voudrais d'abord dire que avant
d'être députés je suis père de famille
moi j'ai trois enfants qui ont quel âge
ils sont grands maintenant 29 25 et 19
ils ont eu 12 ans j'ai deux petites
filles qui vont avoir 12 ans et cet
après-midi c'est pas le député qui
parlait c'est le citoyen en colère parce
que si le gouvernement avait mis en
oeuvre la décision de justice convote
nous en tant que député Lola elle sera
encore parmi nous donc le fond du
problème c'est que dans ce pays on fait
trop de loi et si on n'est pas capable
de les appliquer c'est là où il y a une
défiance envers nos concitoyens alors on
comprend que vous soyez paire de famille
tous les gens voilà qui ont des petites
sœurs des petits frères des des
ils se mettent tous à la place de la
famille de Lola on imagine tous et on
sait tous moi je voilà j'arrête pas
d'avoir des images je me dis ce qu'elle
a subi et on entend parler dans un
instant avec Michel marine c'est c'est
abominable mais est-ce que vous trouvez
que c'était le moment des ce mardi d'en
parler à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
qu'il faut pas attendre un petit peu
est-ce que ces moments d'avoir des
altercations comme ça avec notre
ministre de la Justice aujourd'hui alors
que vraiment là toute la France ne pense
qu'à se recueillir et qu'à essayer de de
que ça ne se reproduise plus et surtout
essayer de d'aider la famille qui doit
être dans un désarroi terrible mais là
on avait le cas d'une personne qui avait
une décision de justice pour quitter le
territoire combien il y en a d'autres
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas d'autre Lola
en potentiel il y a 80% des obligations
de quitter le territoire qui sont pas
appliquées dans notre pays donc moi je
veux bien que c'était peut-être un peu
tôt mais si ça permet d'en sauver
d'autres des Lola et ben tant mieux mais
je vous le dis la loi on en parle tout
le temps ici Gilles Verdez pour vous
entendez donc
Eric poger député et républicains dire
que c'est de la faute du gouvernement je
suis choqué monsieur le député
respectueusement je trouve ça d'abord
indécent et ensuite faux alors indécent
parce que on est dans le drame un drame
épouvantable abominable et c'est vrai
que pour moi je vous ai écouté je vous
entends là vous surfez entre guillemets
là-dessus pour récupérer politiquement
un drame qui est bouleverse la France
entière et deuxièmement c'est faux vous
le savez très bien parce que elle avait
un mois cette personne pour partir de
son plein gré encore aurait-il fallu que
l'Algérie donne des documents
consulaires donc elle ne pouvait partir
pas que le ministère d'intérieur et les
services de police doivent la
identifier la gérer et gérer le départ
volontaire pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait
on peut pas suivre on peut pas suivre
tous les cas vous le savez très bien il
faut pas faire des lois qui ne sont pas
applicables
la défiance qui a dans notre société
aujourd'hui qui fait qu'il y a 20 %
d'extrême d'un côté 20% d'extrême droite
et 50% des français qui vont plus voter
c'est ça mature de famille et qu'on a
des enfants et les petits enfants et ben
on a la colère qui vous montre Mathieu
moi ce que j'aimerais juste te dire
c'est évidemment j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour la famille et je veux pas
lui faire de peine mais je pense qu'au
contraire il faut vraiment vraiment que
la politique dès aujourd'hui s'empare de
ce drame je trouvais pas que c'est trop
tôt non je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
que si on ne s'en empare pas tout de
suite ce sera un fait divers un simple
fait divers or si on veut pas que ce
soit un fait divers mais si on veut que
ça ne se reproduise plus jamais il n'y a
que la politique qui peut résoudre ce
problème et je pense que Lola doit être
malheureusement non pas plus qu'un
symbole ils doivent véritablement servir
de j'aurais encore Gilles qui souligne
un problème mais sans solution oui
effectivement 80% des personnes ne sont
pas reconnues à la frontière mais on ne
peut rien y faire non justement c'est à
la politique de son appareil ce qui est
arrivé là ça relève même plus la
criminalité c'est de la barbarie et on
voit ça tous les jours donc je pense
vraiment au contraire que c'est à
l'Assemblée nationale maintenant de
régler ce problème parce qu'on en a
marre alors Michel maryte avec nous
Michel
c'est un grand spécialiste des faits
divers vous êtes journaliste au niveau
détective je vous connais extrêmement
bien voilà je on vous suive vous êtes le
plus grand spécialiste que s'est-il
passé vendredi
alors j'ai essayé de faire un exposé
assez assez court et assez
compréhensible vendredi
à 15h15 environ
Lola sort de ses cours pour rentrer chez
elle un petit peu plus tard j'ai pas
essayé de pas se noyer dans les horaires
un petit peu plus tard ses parents se
rendent compte qu'elle n'est pas rentrée
s'inquiète parce que le temps a passé et
comme ils sont gardiens de cette
immeuble de l'immeuble où ils habitent
ils ont accès à la vidéo surveillance
donc ils vont visionner les images pour
voir si à tout hasard leur fille ne
serait pas passé par là et peut-être
aller voir une copine enfin essayer de
retrouver une trace de son passage et là
ils vont effectivement voir qu'à 15h30
un peu plus tard peut-être 40 je sais
plus l'horaire
on voit Lola qui passe le portail elle
est accompagnée d'une jeune femme une
jeune femme sur le moment les parents ne
reconnaissent pas cette femme
et comme elle n'est pas allée chez elle
qu'elle était en présence de cette femme
qu'elle ne connaissent qu'il ne
connaissent pas il s'inquiète à tort
pardon une cinquième juste raison et ils
vont au commissariat qui est à 200
mètres de leur domicile centrale 19 et
ils vont signaler la disparition de
leurs filles les policiers prennent ça
très au sérieux commencent à faire un
certain nombre d'investigation dans le
dans le quartier et après on passe à
23h15 je reviendrai évidemment un petit
peu en arrière après 23h15 il y a un SDF
qui découvre dans les parties communes
de la résidence une malle une mal en
plastique recouverte d'une couverture
rouge et alors est-ce qu'il avait
l'intention de voir ce qu'il y avait
dedans peu importe bref il ouvre cette
malle et ce qu'il voit évidemment et
saisissance est un le corps d'une d'une
jeune fille atrocement mutilé
il prévient la police enfin il fait
prévenir la police parce qu'il a pas de
portable la brigade criminelle pour là
encore faire un raccourci arrive très
rapidement sur place et commence les
investigations les investigations là je
pense qu'on peut leur
coûter des coups de chapeau parce que
ils sont saisis à minuit et quelques et
à 7h du matin ils avaient interpellé
l'auteur et trois autres suspects
donc ils font les premières
constatations très vite on fait le lien
avec cette femme qu'on a sur la sur la
vidéo surveillance un certain nombre de
témoins l'ont vu elle était totalement
incohérente elle se baladait avec cette
malle extrêmement lourde et un dernier
témoin vient dire mais si moi je l'ai vu
monter dans une voiture une Dacia
il donne l'heure précise et ils ont
chargé une malle ils sont partis
ensemble et fort heureusement la vidéo
surveillance est un précieux allié de la
police en général et la police
judiciaire en particulier ils ont la
plaque d'immatriculation de cette
voiture donc ils peuvent l'identifier il
ça leur donne une adresse à Asnières ils
vont se transporter à Asnières
interpellé le propriétaire de la voiture
qui d'ailleurs leur permettra de d'avoir
l'adresse de Bois-Colombes où ils vont à
7h du matin pouvoir interpeller la
fameuse DAB
donc c'est Damien c'est la principale
suce Dabia c'est la principale c'est
celle qu'on voit sur la vidéo c'est
c'est elle
et c'est elle qui a reconnu l'effet
alors de façon très très anarchique
à la reconnu les faits puis plus puis
voilà c'est globalement je pense qu'il y
a pas de grosses erreurs quand sont sa
participation fait après elle donne des
détails qui sont impossibles on va
peut-être pas se perdre dans les détails
alors elle a reconnu l'effet elle a été
mise en examen pour meurtre aggraver
viol aggravé acte de torture et de
barbarie elle encourt la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité sachant que
c'est sur une mineure de moins de 15 ans
justement à 15h 30 donc à peu près la
petite Lola donc rentre du collège et là
qu'est-ce qui se passe
à 15h30 quand elle sort du collège
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle rencontre
cette belle rencontre cette
Dabia devant les devants
sa soeur qui est locataire en titre d'un
appartement dans l'immeuble de donc qui
est dans la résidence dans l'immeuble au
dessus de du domicile des parents de
larmes on est contre c'est dans
l'immeuble
et donc là
on a lu on a eu plein de choses
qu'est-ce qui va se passer elle elle
arrive alors il y a des choses qu'on
peut lire des choses qu'on peut pas dire
parce qu'on est
je vous m'excuserez ma pudeur mais vous
avez bien raison
quand elle l'enferme dans l'appartement
de sa soeur elle l'oblige à prendre une
douche donc lui demande de se
déshabiller et elle lui demande de faire
sa toilette
ensuite elle va avoir des des
attouchements d'ordre sexuel à caractère
sexuel
réciproque elle lui impose de faire un
certain nombre de choses et elle lui
fait un certain nombre de choses je
crois que ce soit utile
tout ça dure en tout deux heures quand
même et
elle l'attache la Bayonne et c'est
d'ailleurs ce bâillon qui sera à
l'origine de sa mort puisque les causes
de la mort selon le médecin légiste
c'est l'étouffement elle s'est étouffée
probablement dans
il y a pas eu que ça mais c'est la
principale cause de la mort c'est
l'étouffement et post mortem elle va
donner un certain nombre de coups de
couteau de coups de ciseaux également
elle va massacrer ce pauvre petit ce
pauvre petit corps
elle dira un certain nombre de choses je
pense pas que ça soit très utile de
les jours je sens quel genre de choses
elle a déclaré qu'elle avait bu le sang
de sa victime
et a priori ça semble pas possible
d'accord
pourquoi on a évoqué la piste du trafic
d'organes dans cette affaire à un moment
c'est elle qui en parle à un témoin
enfin c'est des Roumains je crois qui
était dans une camionnette parce qu'elle
était perdue là sur ce trottoir de la
rue de la rue Manin et elle cherchait
quelqu'un pour pour charger la demander
à quelqu'un de charger la malle pas du
tout au courant de ce qu'il y avait
dedans
les gens non ne savaient pas ce qu'il y
avait dedans et un moment elle a dit
dans la conversation je travaille pour
un don d'organe enfin elle fait une
allusion au don d'organe bon les robes
de la tuer
manifestement
c'est pas on appartenu l'après
méditation c'est la seule chose qu'on
retienne pas
parce que ça se passe le meurtre donc
c'est pas c'est évidemment sans
préméditation la qualification
criminelle qu'on retenue il y a trois
juge d'instruction dans cette affaire
les trois juges d'instructions sont
tombés d'accord pour ne pas retenir
l'après méditation
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'il y a eu
un enchaînement d'événements qui ont
amené à la mort le fait qu'elle soit
bâillonnée c'est pour l'empêcher de
parler forcément pour la tuer et
peut-être qu'elle est morte entre
guillemets accidentellement mais je
voudrais surtout mal suite à la malle
elle la trouve chez sa sœur elle a en
fait un cadavre d'un enfant de 12 ans au
domicile de sa sœur sa sœur était pas
présente sa sœur était au travail
elle allait rentrer du travail et donc
elle a cherché une solution
pour pour débarrasser le corps de
l'appartement
les parents n'ont été gardiens de cet
immeuble
il la connaissait
alors les parents connaissent la soeur
d'accord et
curieusement on parle d'une altercation
je crois que c'est a eu lieu sauf que la
mer ne s'en souvient pas ne se souvient
pas d'avoir une altercation avec cette
femme et le père le mât le mari plutôt
dit ouais samedi vaguement quelque chose
mais c'est la suspecte qui a dit qu'elle
avait une altercation avec eux à cause
d'un digicode c'est ça voilà c'est elle
qui dit ça c'est l'auteur qui dit en
garde à vue qu'elle a une altercation
avec les gardiens à propos d'un c'est
pas le winpin digicode c'est le quoi
comme elle habite à chez sa sœur et
qu'elle avait pas le bip pour accéder
c'était compliqué pour elle de d'aller
venir d'aller faire une course de
revenir il fallait qu'elle attende que
quelqu'un lui ouvre la porte et donc
elle avait réclamé un bip au gardien qui
a juste titre ne lui avait pas accordé
bien sûr elle a rien à faire là et non
pas de de raison qu'elle est qu'elle est
un bip
alors elle a donc raconté donc cette
altercation ce serait pour elle le
mobile
alors la police judiciaire la justice le
tour le système judiciaire est bien
embêté avec cette histoire parce que
c'est la seule explication qu'elle donne
dans un débit de de de phrase très
compliquées
c'est la seule justification qu'on
puisse trouver il y en a pas d'autre ne
fait pas allusion à d'autres incidents
qui pourraient expliquer si tenter qu'on
puisse expliquer un tel crime
donc le fait qu'elle se soit embrouillée
avec les gardiens c'est tout ce qu'il y
a pour justifier qu'elle ait voulu se
venger elle attendait elle attendait la
petite la petite Lola ou bien elle dit
qu'elle la croise qu'elle allait elle
rentrait à l'appartement et qu'elles
sont arrivées en même temps maintenant
il est possible qu'elle l'ait attendue
mais si elle l'avait attendu elle serait
poursuivie pour il y aurait une
prémilisation
aujourd'hui
elle est elle se trouve où cette cette
fête a été faire serrer à Fleury-Mérogis
au quartier des femmes on l'a mis à
l'isolement elle est surveillée on la
surveille comme le lait sur le feu parce
que c'est pas le moment qu'elle aille se
suicider ou enfin et c'est difficile de
la mélanger avec les autres détenus
parce que
on lui donne pas 10 minutes de survie
dans dans le milieu carcéral si elle est
si elle est pas protégée donc elle est à
l'isolement surveillée H24 et on attend
en réalité les expertsys psychiatriques
pour savoir si il va pas falloir la
transférer à Fresnes où elle serait
soignée entre guillemets donc voilà donc
là c'est là où je voulais en venir
on dit qu'elle est déséquilibrée
c'est très grave ça c'est
là que je voulais parce que exactement
voilà ça c'est très grave
si les psychiatres estiment que sont
discernement est altéré il prononceront
les responsabilité pénale il y aura pas
de
et ça aujourd'hui donc là on va voir son
profil psychiatrique là dans les
prochains jours
je pense que compte tenu de de
la médiatisation de cette affaire de
l'importance que
qui a pris cette affaire les magistrats
instructeurs vont
demander les expertises psychiatriques
en urgence et d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est quand même très important de
savoir
alors moi je pose une question et je
suis sûr que tous les Français qui nous
regardent ce soir en direct se disent la
même chose pour moi ce serait un drame
absolu absolu vraiment
que les psychiatres disent elle est
irresponsable parce que si elle est
irresponsable il va se passer quoi alors
en France on juge pas les fous c'est ça
donc si elle est abolie de son
discernement c'est l'article 12-1 ou 122
je me rappelle plus passer un des deux
l'abolition du discernement veut dire
qu'elle est soignée elle est dans les
mains des médecins de la médecine vous
rendez compte peut-être que dans 4-5 ans
il sera libérée
peuvent la croiser dans 4-5 ans dans la
rue
moi je vous dis à chaque jour ici je
j'ai l'impression aux yeux je deviens
fou je fais cette émission je sais pas
ce qu'on pense que tous les soirs je
deviens fou ce joli on est dans un pays
de malade voilà je vous lis les fous
c'est nous l'anticipons pas c'est pas
fait je le vois j'ai très peur que ça
arrive je vous dis franchement j'ai très
peur que ça arrive parce que je lis
beaucoup d'articles là dessus je vois
beaucoup c'est une déséquilibrée c'était
l'objet de ma question cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée justement j'ai conclu avec
ce sujet là en disant j'espère qu'il y
aura un procès pour Lola parce que les
faisceaux actuels sont en train de nous
amener sur la voie de la responsabilités
c'est ce que c'est ce que c'est ce que
je sens pour pointer et qui me fait
extrêmement peur et Michel Marie alors
dans ce cas-là donc c'est ce que vous
dites elle pourrait être soignée et
sortir dans quatre ans alors ça c'est
l'abolitionnement il y a un
intermédiaire c'est l'altération
d'accord donc c'est un mi-chemin si vous
voulez qui entraîne une réduction de
peine c'est à dire qu'on peut pas lui
coller le maximum prévu par la loi qui
est la personne je pense qu'on redescend
à 20 ans ou peut-être à 30 je ne sais
pas mais je vais vous dire quelque chose
qui va peut-être choqué pour moi c'est
je vais vous dire si on a toutes les
preuves pour moi là je excuse-moi Gilles
mais pour moi c'est c'est je veux dire
c'est perpétuité direct je suis désolé
je suis désolé je suis désolé il y a pas
d'altération ni de je suis désolé ni de
nos discernement
je suis désolé moi pour moi c'est c'est
le genre de c'est le genre de cas ou fou
ou pas elle doit être en prison elle ne
doit pas être soignée je suis désolé
Gilbert je sais que je vais peut-être
vous vous choquer mais je vous dis c'est
c'est inadmissible moi une petite fille
de 12 ans si elle ressort dans 4-5 ans
je suis désolé moi les parents la
famille tous même nous voilà et tous
vous rendez compte le traumatisme
pour moi il y a même pas de débats c'est
si je suis désolé c'est c'est perpétude
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez euh
Gilles Verdez donc sauf que Cyril on est
pas psychiatre si encore une fois je me
je vais pas du tout atténué le le je
supporte plus ce genre de excusez-moi je
ne supporte plus ce genre de de de
phrase qui qui font qu'aujourd'hui il y
a des choses incroyables qui se passent
aujourd'hui en France et Gilles Verdez
on n'est pas psychiatre je suis désolé
là pour moi pour moi pour moi la même
pas besoin d'expertise psychiatrique
pour moi je suis désolé
ne me faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas
dit je dis que si jamais il y a une
abolition du discernement c'est à dire
que s'il est prouvé qu'elle ne savait
pas c'est ça bolition discernement
pas conscient de ses actes ou pas pour
moi bah ça justement ça c'est une loi
qui doit être révisée aussi je suis
désolé penser aux parents
en France en France en France moi j'en
peux plus de ça je vous dis la vérité en
tant que c'est ce genre de discours
c'est insupportable et les lois d'ochons
les Mathieu je sais pas ce que tu en
penses mais là c'est très bien parce
qu'en fait tout est mis sur le sur le
sur le plateau aujourd'hui on a une
personne qui est sur un territoire de
manière illégale et qui va créer qui va
commettre un crime horrible et qui de
surcroît peut-être maintenant va être
jugé irresponsable exactement
c'est la totale et on est en train de
montrer toutes les failles bien sûr les
failles de ce pays aujourd'hui voilà
pourquoi j'ai tout à l'heure défendu
monsieur député parce que je pense que
maintenant il faut vraiment que les
politiques mais encore une fois que ce
soit pas un fait divers que une semaine
on parle d'autre chose que la politique
s'empare de sale de manière mais est-ce
que je vous jure on sait tous mis à la
place de la de la famille mais même Lola
on a au moins je l'ai ressenti je vous
dis comme quelqu'un de ma famille je
sais pas pour vous mais je pense que
tous les Français il y a pas aujourd'hui
députés pour ça aujourd'hui
que la personne va peut-être avoir une
expertise cicatrique et voilà il s'en
sortir même si pour moi c'est pour moi
je comprends pour moi c'est super
pétuité direct excusez-moi je sais pas
mais c'est quoi alors on fait quoi
on la maintient pour moi là
on en est pas là il ne devrait jamais
sortir d'un établissement psychiatrique
s'il s'avérait qu'il y avait abolition
mais monsieur le député vous voulez
changer la loi là-dessus c'est-à-dire
que vous voulez qu'on assure
il faut faire au cas par cas je veux en
ce qui concerne cette personne si la loi
avait exécutée elle serait pas sur le
territoire français
Lola serait parmi nous ça c'est le
premier étape deuxième élément on ne
juge pas les fous ça fait partie de
notre de nos fondamentaux par contre on
s'assure qu'elle est advitable eternale
que ce soit une adhésion ou un hôpital
psychiatrique mais qu'elle ne sortent
plus que la société soit protégée c'est
ça le le même problème le problème c'est
que quand ils arrivent en psychiatrie on
maîtrise plus rien la justice d'ailleurs
ne maîtrise voilà c'est sous le
responsabilité de la médecine du médecin
et je peux vous garantir que j'ai
assisté à des procès j'en ai un en
mémoire ou le type était interné il
avait des permissions pour aller se
balader dans l'après-midi c'est ça la
première permission qu'il a dont il a
bénéficié il a tué un petit garçon voilà
voilà voilà voilà donc quand je disais
perpétuité tout à l'heure c'est ce que
vous dites voilà on va pas être enfermé
à vitam eternam c'est tout voilà
protéger la société
exactement
l'état de droit dans lequel on est ne
protège pas les victimes et ne protège
pas les citoyens il est plus favorable
malheureusement au meurtrier au
délinquant co victime alors justement
est-ce que trop de droits tu le droit
elle a un avocat
je l'ai croisé quoi lui donc voilà il va
plaider la folie les responsabilités
c'est parce qu'il va plaider mais il est
très bavard et il nous explique un
avocat c'est ça va être compliqué donc
c'est le seul avocat qui fait du pénal
qui ne parle pas aux journalistes
Michelin on sait qu'elle
[Musique]
la principale suspecte on est obligé de
dire suspecte pour l'instant
présumé présumé coupable oui c'est
peut-être mieux à donner plusieurs
versions
qu'est-ce qu'il a donné comme version en
fait elle donne plusieurs versions mais
ça revient sensiblement tout même c'est
elle fait des variantes sur
des détails
quand vous dites qu'elle a donné
plusieurs versions en fait elle a
reconnu l'effet puis elle s'est
rétractée puis elle a reconnu l'effet et
elle a baladé en fait les enquêteurs
comme ça et après non en gros elle donne
à peu près toujours à quelques variantes
près il dit la même chose quand elle
reconnaît elle reconnaît ce qu'on ce
qu'on sait ce que je vous ai expliqué
tout à l'heure et quand elle reconnaît
pas elle dit non c'est pas moi alors
vous dites que sa sœur travaillait elle
elle faisait quoi de ses journées elle
était arrivée en 2016 avec le statut des
cassisante je ne sais pas ce qu'elle
étudier
en tout cas notre travail pas ma
connaissance
elle était entraînée dans la rue elle
était dans le quartier
depuis quelques temps chez sa sœur mais
elle avait un nouveau petit copain à
Bois-Colombes chez qui elle a passé la
dernière nuit sa dernière nuit de
liberté et le type donc on peut avoir du
discernement pour un petit copain mais
voilà ça ça m'en fous ça marche
le copain qui est venu la chercher et
qui quand il a découvert ce qu'il y
avait dans la malle elle a appelé un
Hubert pour que tout pour tout dégager
c'est un élément que j'avais pas ça donc
son petit copain est venu alors c'est
c'est pas un petit coin sympa avec
lequel elle a des relations
voilà ok d'accord elle l'appelle ce
jour-là quand elle est avec la malle sur
lui dit rien elle l'a vient me chercher
lui pense qu'elle a envie de penser de
passer un moment agréable avec avec lui
donc il vient la chercher il charge la
malle les valises pensant que c'est des
affaires comme elle est toujours entre
deux domicile peut-être que c'est ses
affaires ça garde-robe et il ramène tout
ça chez lui donc à Asnières il reste
deux heures à Asnières et à un moment il
se rend compte de ce qu'il y a dans la
malle et là
il appelle un Hubert et il redescend la
main les valises et Dabia et ce qui lui
vaut d'être poursuivi pour celle de
cadavre
c'est incroyable et elle revient ensuite
dans le 19ème sur les lieux du crime
c'est là où je dis qu'elle va pas bien
quand même parce que
ne vous en déplace je vais vous en veux
pas du tout à vous vous devez relater
les faits vous le faites extrêmement
bien je vous le dis et vraiment
heureusement que je suis très content de
vous avoir ce soir que nous à continuer
les choses voilà c'est ce drame mais
c'est vrai que quand on dit elle n'est
pas bien moi je vais vous dire moi je
peux plus j'en peux plus d'entendre de
ça il n'est pas bien il est déséquilibré
il est ça c'est devenu la principale
défense des avocats dans ce genre de
drame et je vous le dis c'est un
deuxième drame pour la famille et je
sais qu'on en est pas encore là mais
juste j'allerte et j'ai peur j'espère
qu'on sera pas encore dans un cas comme
celui-ci oui et Kelly est-ce qu'on a le
témoignage de sa sœur qui nous parle
d'antécédents qui là-bas qui celles qui
la connaît le mieux qu'on connaît est-ce
qu'il y a la des antécédents
psychologiques psychiatrique elle a des
problèmes effectivement la sœur fait
état de problèmes en disant qu'elle est
arrivée donc en 2016 en France
euh elle avait perdu ses parents elle
avait été agressé sexuellement d'après
la sœur
justement je voudrais juste en Algérie
je voudrais juste parler de ça deux
petites secondes parce que j'ai vu dans
un de ces témoignages qu'elle disait je
n'ai aucune compassion pour Lola moi
aussi j'ai souffert ouais c'est ce
qu'elle aurait dit j'ai pas cette info
alors
voilà c'est ce qu'elle aurait dit elle
aurait dit moi aussi j'ai souffert voilà
et ton petit donc je elle a un éprouvé
aucune
aucun remords aucun aucune peine elle a
dit moi aussi j'ai souffert en étant
jeune et donc ça corrobore un petit peu
ce qu'elle aurait dit puisque vous voyez
que parce que je sais pas en revanche
que
je répondrai après
des policiers lui ont montré les les
photos de son carnage elle est restée
glaciale c'est ça ouais donc ce corbeau
effectivement
si je peux
la sœur dit que elle a eu des problèmes
en Algérie a été victime de elle parle
de viol je crois
qu'elle a perdu ses parents en Algérie
c'est la raison pour laquelle pour
laquelle pardon elle quitte l'Algérie
pour venir en France avec un visa
étudiant donc on est en 2016 elle est
victime de cool de violence conjugales
lorsqu'elle avait dû se mettre en couple
avec un quelqu'un en 2018
et après elle devient en irrégularité
alors je sais pas si elle a fait des
études ou pas et la soeur pour finir dit
que depuis quelques mois elle avait un
peu déraillé